[Music]
on this week's fyi we head to downing
street to put your questions about the
war in ukraine to the prime minister
boris johnson
with russian attacks on ukrainian cities
still on the increase is there anything
more britain can do to help stop the
bombing and are we about to see many
more refugees coming into the uk
war in ukraine in eastern europe is now
over three weeks old and for many people
the conditions are worse than ever
russian forces have stepped up their
bombardment of towns and cities with
some places like the besieged city of
mariappol suffering awful damage now
around 3 million refugees have managed
to flee the country and most of them
have been warmly welcomed into
neighbouring countries but the british
government has faced criticism by only
allowing a couple thousand refugees into
the uk so far now with all this
suffering going on in ukraine i think it
must be hard for our parents let alone
us to understand why this is happening
and why russia would do this so we went
to the home of the british prime
minister number 10 downing street in
london to put your questions and
concerns to boris johnson in an
exclusive interview
[Music]
to start off with thank you so much for
joining us today prime minister nice
absolute pleasure braden and and
scarlett good to see you again now we
know that the situation is really bad in
ukraine don't we you know how
devastating it is yes but i think the
center of attention that a lot of people
want to know and many kids want to know
is is there going to be a world war 3
and another thing that i know a lot of
kids are really worried about is the
introduction of nuclear weapons so what
is happening
i think it's very important for us to
understand what's happening in ukraine
this is a
a a war
of a conventional war
by
vladimir putin to conquer and subjugate
to crush
a totally innocent country
and a totally innocent civilian
population who've done nothing wrong
none of them and what he's doing is i've
never seen such a clear
difference between good and evil
and i think that
what he wants is to get away with it
and in order to get away with it he's
going to try to sound threatening
to the rest of the world about what
could happen including use of the types
of weapons that you describe
i think it's very important that we
treat that as a complete distraction
this is about helping the people of
ukraine to protect themselves they have
every right to defend themselves a lot
of people think that president putin is
a very bad person what did you think of
him when you met him
i think that he is a
guy who
grew up in the
the cold war
he's a
secret service man he's a kgb man he's a
russian spy that's how he thinks he
believes that the west
countries like ours are trying to
encircle russia and threaten russia and
he's obsessed with that idea
and he's wrong
and i think that he
was very shocked and upset
by the way the
soviet union collapsed
in
the 1990s the early 1990s
and
he thought that that was a
humiliation for
for russia
and what he's trying to do now is to
is to rebuild as much of the the old
soviet union as he can
and you're far too young to remember
what it was like but it was a pretty
grim communist
socialist entity
and it uh
was held together by force
now as day goes on you know day by day
by day more innocent people are being
killed and more cities are really being
destroyed and obliterated so when is
enough enough
it's already way way way way past enough
it's a it's appalling and i don't think
anybody expected to see something like
this in in europe we haven't seen
anything like this in europe
really since the second world war eighty
years ago
and
we
i think
people in european governments in
western governments are struggling to
understand
what's happening and how to deal with it
and i think we're all realizing that
we're gonna have to do more we have to
do more to support uh the ukrainians but
what we can't do is
allow putin
to start framing this
start claiming that this is a war
between him and the west it's not it's
about him trying to crush ukraine
and
other people around the world thinking
that that's not fair that's not right if
he does get you know a hold of ukraine
and he does almost conquer ukraine what
about countries like finland and sweden
that aren't in nato aren't they at
really severe risk
that i'm afraid exactly what they think
the finns in particular their
traditional posture
has been
of strict neutrality
they haven't been members of nato but i
think there's a pretty big debate going
on right now in finland as you can
imagine what i feel most is that putin
should recognize that the international
court of justice has ruled this is a
genocide
what he's doing is is a war crime
and
i think if there's going to be any hope
for him
uh
he's got to pull back immediately he's
got to stop this and he's got to take
his troops home why isn't the uk doing
more than
the uk has
progressively been doing more and more
and
i it's not a competition but the uk
began by being the first european
country to to give military assistance
we're the biggest donor of humanitarian
aid to the region
and uh we will continue to do
as much as we possibly can and i think
we'll do that because we know that
that's what the british people want
president putin and the russian
government has been telling i'm sure you
know many russian people and many
russian kids false you know fake news
and not actually telling them what is
going on in ukraine and what's going on
in their neighboring country so as the
uk how can we make sure that the kids in
the uk only hear the truth and know what
is the truth i think it's very important
that kids in the uk should have access
to the best possible
information about what's going on and
i i think that sky has been covering it
very fairly and very well and
i think that you should try and share as
much of that
you know good
valuable authenticated material as you
can i find it so upsetting because i
mean russian citizens who are meant to
be following president putin don't want
this themselves so they don't and i
think it's very important that we should
but one of the things i think that
you know you could you could do is just
reach out to young russians
and say you know is this really being
done in your name
is this what you want because i bet they
don't if they they knew they understood
what was happening i bet they wouldn't
support it
do you feel bad that the uk hasn't taken
in more refugees when you know some
places like poland and neighbouring
countries have taken in close to two
million
they have but of course the the the uk
doesn't have a a border so we haven't
received the first wave but we are
taking many many more now as they as
people decide to come on to
to the uk and that's right we've got an
amazing record as a country for taking
people in and we understand the
importance of it and the the benefit
that
um
uh
refugees get but also the benefit that
the country gets from from from taking
people in
we've got a plan
which was announced a few days ago so
that if you if you if you want to
welcome
um
a ukrainian family or ukrainian refugees
into your into your own home or evacuees
into your own home
then the government will support you and
we're seeing massive generosity already
by the by the british people well
following on for that will you be
housing any refugees here well i i'm a
mere uh
tenant of this i'm not even a tenant i'm
a i don't i don't know what my status is
exactly i'm i'm the temporary occupant
of this uh
of this place
um it is up to
uh to to others to decide how that would
work but if if it were to be possible
i'm sure uh people would welcome it i'm
sure that i'm sure there are a lot of
people here who would who would want to
do it
from all these things happening have you
not had enough of being the prime
minister or having this job
well you know i think that i'm aware
that there are some people who uh think
that uh you know
that um some members of the opposition
uh who had uh like to remove me from
office but that's their job
uh my job is to my job is to is to
continue and
i think that
um
you know the the great thing about
about democratic politics
is that we have a we have a system
whereby the people
can remove you
and
that's what they don't have
in russia
and it's what they have in ukraine
in ukraine
the people could vote out
the president and the prime minister and
the government
in russia if you stand against vladimir
putin you're probably going to be shot
or poisoned
that's the difference that's why ukraine
matters thank you so much for joining us
prime minister and thank you for your
time and you and thank you braden
scarlett thank you thank you very much
and for the full interview with boris
johnson head to our webpage at first dot
news forward slash fyi you'll also find
our i don't get it explainer there
looking into why russia invaded ukraine
and how world leaders are trying to
bring a peaceful end to the war
[Music]
many of the three million refugees who
fled the war in ukraine have escaped
into neighboring countries carrying just
a few belongings they've crossed into
moldova romania hungary slovakia and
poland with some then heading to other
eu countries locals have been praised
for showing great generosity
this was the welcome that ten-year-old
dimitri and eight-year-old victoria
received at their new school in naples
in italy
but countries like poland are now
getting overwhelmed they've taken in
close to two million refugees and it
puts the spotlight back onto the uk
which up to now has faced a lot of
criticism for not doing enough many
refugees including veronica's family
said the process for letting them in is
way too slow and way too difficult
veronica's dad actually lives in the uk
and he traveled to the ukraine polish
border a day after the war broke out to
pick up veronica and a mother
unfortunately they told us that getting
back into the uk was really tough so
they wanted to share their story on fyi
when the war broke out i felt a lot of
pain because i understood i had to leave
my country my relatives my dog my
friends my school
when we got to the french border they
wouldn't let us through
the french police came they took us out
and we had to go to the embassy in paris
we were told they can't help us after
driving across europe to get to france
the uk border force in calais wouldn't
let veronica and her family into the uk
for over a week they sent them back and
forth between the british embassy and
the uk visa processing center over 10
times it was an especially hard time
because veronica suffers from diabetes
an illness where her blood sugar levels
can go dangerously high if she doesn't
take her medication or eat the right
food
because i had to go back and forth a few
times my sugar level was very high and i
felt terrible we took very little stuff
with us very little medication very
little food they should understand our
situation the stress we are in because i
ran from the bombs in ukraine
and i ran to my father who is a uk
citizen i wanted to stay with my father
in the uk for safety
i hope that other families who are going
to arrive in the uk will face less
difficulties
finally uk authorities granted veronica
and her mother their visas so they could
get to the ferry in the uk with
veronica's dad
but the pain isn't over for the family
as the war in ukraine continues they're
worried about veronica's older brother
dennis who had to stay behind and fight
veronica was too upset to talk about her
brother but her mum oksana wanted us to
know how worried they are about him even
because my son has disabilities he has
diabetes and hearing aids i thought he
would be allowed out of the country
because he's technically not eligible to
serve in the armed forces
when we approached border control they
wouldn't let him pass out of the country
i had such a dilemma
i wanted both my kids to be safe
but he insisted
go
take veronica dad will meet you on the
other side
the day before yesterday he took an oath
to defend our country but i'm terribly
worried because he has hearing
difficulties if he hears a command to
run he might not hear it properly and
won't be able to follow instructions
the family speak to dennis every day and
at the moment he says things are quiet
where he isn't an opal in western
ukraine but the battery on his hearing
aid is low and he's running out of his
medicine for diabetes
make sure to take your medicine
regularly
only a few pharmacies into nothing have
insulin
we'll try and send you some over
beyond them i don't believe this is
happening in our country
i want all our boys to come back in one
piece
i hope for ukrainian victory and the
country builds itself back and i will be
able to return that
we love you so much
hold on be strong
[Music]
as the prime minister mentioned the uk
government have now set up a new scheme
it's called homes for ukraine and
british people can sign up on a website
to donate a room or home to a refugee
and volunteers will be paid 350 pounds a
month to be a host and in the first day
alone over 100 000 people signed up but
critics of the scheme including the
opposition labour party say that there's
not enough urgency and that the visa
application process is way too
complicated
well that's about it for this week but
we're going to leave you with some
images of the many british children
coming together to support ukraine and
they've been raising money by going to
school dressed in ukrainian colours see
you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you